[Music]
in the future it will not be so odd for
people who are raising children to have
part-time jobs both of them and that
that will be seen as a normal thing to
do so I'm very optimistic that change
will come even if you're not planning to
have a spouse and your own children
you're still part of a family and one of
the topics we have actually is elder
care how are you going to be dealing
with your parents when they get older
and just about everybody has parents so
the family writ large your family of
origin your family a nuclear family that
you may start or have already started
how are you going to balance work and
family in your in your life and balance
maybe the wrong word because probably
there is no balance so how are you going
to combine them how are you going to
have a satisfying family life and a
satisfying career
[Music]
often somebody says well I'm my mother's
going to come and take care of the kids
while I work and I always think okay
have you asked your mother and often
they have not so I say well you know the
first step of your plan is to ask your
mother and some of them come back the
next session and say oh my mother says
no thanks and I've been there done that
I'm not going to be taking care of your
children so it's a chance for people to
be real and also with regard to elder
care generally we have very generous
people in the class who say that what
they'll do when their parents or parent
needs care is they'll bring that parent
into their house and I say well do you
know if that's what your mother or your
father or your mother-in-law wants well
no we haven't had that conversation
we'll have that conversation and again
often time oftentimes the parent does
not want that there are still women
including women who are about to get an
MBA who want to take time out who don't
want to come back to work and often
they're the ones who feel deviant
because after all they've got an MBA and
you know presumably they went to that
degree because they want to work but
then they have a child and they want to
take some time off so the question of
how you take time off how much time you
take and most important what you do
while you're out namely you better keep
your networks up and you better keep
your hand in the business so you know
what's going on because if you actually
disappear totally for five years or ten
years for sure you're going to have a
lot of trouble coming back
[Music]
it's really a family decision because if
she leaves the workforce unless your
family is independently wealthy there's
going to be a lot more pressure on you
the man and so you should know that and
you and she should talk about this and
how long is she going to be out for and
what's she going to do to keep her her
finger in it while she's out and maybe
the two of you want to have a different
conversation which is not you know when
should she leave and how should she come
back but maybe you want to talk about
what the two of you can do so that you
can both stay in perhaps you're going to
put more money into hiring a nanny or
you're going to make it worthwhile for
your mother-in-law
to play a bigger role here maybe your
wife can work part time maybe you can
both work part time anyway we're trying
to increase the number of options that
people have and make it a family
decision rather than the woman just
saying oh this is what I want to do you
can't possibly plan everything out you
don't know if a child that you have will
be a special needs child in which case
all of your planning is for naught
because that child is going to take
precedence your decisions are all going
to be about how to help that child and
you know planning or or there's a death
of a spouse in which case everything is
different or even a divorce that you
didn't see coming
so I think planning is a very good thing
but everybody should understand that you
know what's the old saying man plans and
God laughs I mean you just can't
possibly plan out everything
[Music]
what are you going to do in the place
where you work in a large corporation
and a small start-up what are you going
to do personally to help other people to
balance work and family how are you
going to change policies about family
leave what are you going to do about
childcare for your employees and the
people you manage I mean one guy saying
you know I told her when she comes back
she doesn't have to have her old job
back she can be in a much easier job
with less travel and in general there's
at least one woman students at classes
and I don't want that when I come back I
want to be just treated the way I was
before I want the travel I want the
promotions and so men and women get to
see that not everybody has the same view
here some women want to come back and
you know take a slower role for a while
and some don't and the only way to know
this is to actually have a face-to-face
conversation with the employee when
she's ready to come back you know what
what is it that that you see for
yourself and the other thing they learn
is that what you say when you're
pregnant and you've never had a child
before may be different from what you
say when you have had the child
particularly if the child has a problem
of one sort or another and so again
people see that and they learn from each
other
they see what a wide variety of
experiences people have
you